Transcriber: Rayane Baydoun
المدقّق: Christin Melad
بِسْمِ اللّهِ الرَّحْمـَنِ الرَّحِيم
إبداع بين الزيت والماء.
أغلب الأعمال الإبداعية يكون وراءها
أفكار بسيطة للغاية،
لنأخذ فكرة أن الزيت لا يختلط بالماء،
هذه الفكرة البسيطة أن الزيت لا يختلط
بالماء فكرة معروفة لدى الكل،
لكن لها تطبيقات رائعة في الصناعة
وفي الطبيعة.
سنبدأ مع الطبيعة،
هذه الخنفساء تُعرف بخنفساء “ستينوكارا”
تسكن في واحدة من أكثر المناطق
جذبًا في العالم في “ناميبيا“.
لكنها تحصل على الماء كيف؟
بفكرة أن الزيت لا يختلط الماء.
كيف؟
في الصباح الباكر في هذه الصحراء
الهواء يكون رطبًا
وهذه الخنفساء ترفع ظهرها،
وظهر هذه الخنفساء مُغطى بمادة شمعية،
في هذه المادة الشمعية هناك نتوءات،
فوق هذه النتوءات في مناطق صغيرة للغاية
مُحبة للماء،
ولأن الهواء فيه رطوبة فبعض قطرات الماء
تلتصق بهذه النتوءات الصغيرة المُحبة للماء.
طبعًا قطرات الماء تُصبح أكبر بكثير
من هذه النتوءات،
فتتزحلق قطرات الماء على ظهر هذه الخنفساء
المغطاة بالمادة الشمعية،
ولأن الماء لا يختلط بالزيت
تتزحلق قطرات الماء،
فتّصل إلى فم هذه الخنفساء وتَطفئ ظمأَها.
هذا الإبداع هو إبداع بين الزيت والماء.
الحقيقة هذه الفكرة البسيطة،
كل الكائنات الحَيّة قائمة عليها.
لنأخذ مثال آخر،
البروتينات.
كل الأنشطة الفيزيائية
والبيولوجية التي نقوم بها،
هي تقوم بها هذه البروتينات،
كيف تقوم بهذه البروتينات؟
بسببن: هناك التركيبة الكيميائية
والشكل الثلاثي الفيزيائي لهذه البروتينات.
التركيب الكيميائي لهذه البروتينات.
هذه البروتينات تتكون من أحماض أمينية.
نحن نُقّسم الأحماض الأمينية عادة
إلى أحماض مُحبة للماء وكارهة للماء.
والسبب الثاني:
هو الشكل الثلاثي لهذه البروتينات،
الشكل الثلاثي ذات أهمية بالغة
في القيام بوظائفها.
لكن كيف تحافظ هذه البروتينات على أشكالها
الثلاثية؟
بفكرة أن الزيت لا يختلط بالماء.
لأن هذه الأحماض الأمينية مقسمة إلى قسمين
قسم مُحب للماء وقسم كاره للماء.
فعندما نأخذ البروتين ونضعه في محلول مائي،
فالأجزاء المُحبة للماء تروح
يعني تتفاعل مع الماء وتُعرض نفسها للماء،
بينما تلك التي تكره الماء تبتعد
وتنغلق على نفسها،
فتكوّن الشكل الثلاثي للبروتينات،
فتحافظ البروتينات على شكلها الثلاثي
بسبب أن الزيت والماء لا يختلطان.
هذه الفكرة كل الكائنات الحَيّة
قائمة عليها أيضًا،
وهذه البروتينات التي تقوم بكل هذه
الأعمال المعقدة قائمة على فكرة بسيطة،
وهي أن الزيت لا يختلط بالماء.
إبداع بين الزيت والماء.
بهذه الفكرة البسيطة
قام البروفيسور (وايتسايد)
بجامعة هارفارد عام 2007 بإبداع قل نظيره،
حيث قام بإعداد مختبرات بسيطة على ورق.
الفكرة جدًا بسيطة،
ورق فلتر وأقلام شمعية.
نحن نعلم أنه عندما نضع الماء على ورق
فإن الماء ينفذ بكل الإتجاهات.
طبعًا في التفاعلات الكيميائية نحن نريد أن
نوَّجه الماء بإتجاه مُعين.
كيف نوجهه؟
قال: “بوضع حواجز زيتية على الورق،
وبالتالي سيتجه المحلول المائي
بإتجاه مُعين،
وبالتالي سأتحكم في حركة المُرَكَّبات،
وبالتالي أستطيع أن أقوم بعمليات
التفاعل الكيميائي“.
كما نشاهد في هذه الورقة،
هذه ورقة حواجزها أو اللون الأسود،
هو عبارة عن مادة شمعية،
أقلام شمعية وضعها ثم أخذ الورقة وسّخنها،
لما سَّخن الورقة أصبحت هناك هذه
المادة الشمعية نفذت داخل الورقة،
مُكونة حواجز شمعية،
وبالتالي عندما تضع محلول
مائي فإن الماء يتجه بإتجاه مُعين
مبتعدًا عن الجوانب الشمعية،
لأن الماء لا يختلط مع الزيت.
بهذه الفكرة نحن أيضًا قمنا بإعداد
هذه المُختبرات في جامعة السلطان قابوس
بمُختبر على ورق،
وهذا الفيلم الصغير يوضح لكم الفكرة.
هذا محلول مائي كما تشاهد هنا
لأن الأجزاء شمعية،
فالماء يتجه بإتجاه مُعين،
وبالتالي يتحكم في اتجاه سيلان المحلول.
وبهذه الطريقة نستطيع أن نتحكم
في التفاعلات الكيميائية.
طبعًا عشان نقوم بتطبيق مفيد للإنسان،
الفكرة التي قمنا عليها
أنه نحن في المستقبل القريب،
نحتاج إلى مُنتجات تحليلية،
نستطيع أن نحاول أن نضمن
جودة المنتج الغذائي الذي نشتريه.
من هذا الباب قمنا بتطوير بعض
التطبيقات في هذا المجال.
واليوم سأعرض لكم أحد التطبيقات
وهو العسل الطبيعي.
الكثير منا يرغب في شراء عسل طبيعي.
لكن كيف نعرف أن هذا العسل
الذي نشتريه هذا عسل طبيعي.
عادة نحن نعتمد على الثقة بالبائع،
فإذا البائع قال لي هذا عسل طبيعي
أنا أقوم بشرائه.
قمنا بتطوير مُختبر على ورق،
بنفس فكرة أن الزيت والماء لا يختلطان.
الفكرة،
المُختبر مكون من ثلاث أوراق.
الورقة الأولى مادة شمعية صفراء اللون
والأبيض النقطة البيضة هذه،
هذا المكان الذي نضع فيه محلول العسل،
ثم هناك ورقة حمراء،
اللون الأحمر يمثل المادة الشمعية،
واللون الأبيض يمثل المادة
التي تتفاعل مع الماء،
وأخيرًا الورقة البرتقالية أيضًا
مادة شمعية،
وهناك فتحات كما تشاهد هي للمحلول المائي.
كل الذي عليك تساوي هذه الأوراق الثلاثة مع
بعض كما هو موضح في الصورة.
أنت تضع محلول العسل على الورقة الصفراء،
فينفذ إلى الورقة الحمراء
ومنها ينفذ إلى الورقة البرتقالية.
طبعًا نحن في الورقة البرتقالية عالجناها
معالجة كيميائية
بحيث تتفاعل بشكل إنتقائي مع أنواع السكر
الموجودة في العسل،
وبالتالي كل نقطة
ستتفاعل مع نوع مُعين من السكريات،
كما تشاهد هناك ستعطيك اللون أخضر مزرق،
بعد ثلاث دقائق تقريبًا من وضعه
بمحلول العسل.
بعض ما تضعه سيعطيك نتائج
مثل ما أنت تري هنا.
فهناك أربعة أنواع من السكريات نستطيع أن
نحددها خلال ثلاث دقائق،
سكر الجلوكوز والفركتوز والمالتوز والسكروز.
بإستخدام تطبيق هاتف نقال
تصوَّر هذه الورقة،
فهو يحسب لك تركيز الفركتوز على تركيز
الجلوكوز،
فإذا كان التركيز أعلى من واحد
فالعسل الذي معك ممتاز طبيعي.
طيب هذه الفكرة التي قمنا بها طبعًا
في المستقبل إن شاء الله،
نحن نرغب في تطوير أكبر عدد من المنتجات،
بإستخدام تقنية مُختبرة على ورق،
أن الزيت لايختلط بالماء.
ختامًا،
بين الزيت والماء إبداع.
فكل ابداع خلفه فكرة بسيطة.
كم فكرة مُقنعة في ذهنك؟
أطلق لنفسك العنان حتى تكون مبدعًا.
شكرًا جزيلاً لكم.